قال الرئيس الوزراء الهولندي مارك روت ان
هولندا والدنمارك ملتزمتان بتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 واضاف خلال مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك مع الرئيس الاوكراني في قاعده
للقوات الجويه الهولنديه ان تسليم هذه
المقاتلات سيتم بمجرد استيفاء كييف للشروط
مشيرا الى ضمان وجود البنى التحتيه
المناسبه لانطلاق هذه الطائرات من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من جانبه قال بلاده ستتسلم
مقاتلات اف 16 بعد انتهاء تدريب الطيارين
والمهندسين الاوكرانيين على استخدامها وان
عدد الطائرات سيحدد بعد ذلك
من ناحيته اكد قائد القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ميكولا اوليتشوك ان العمل بدا
لتجهيز مدارج الطائرات كي تكون صالحه
للاستخدام ومناسبه لاستقبال مقاتلات اف 16
الامريكيه واضاف ان مدارج الطائرات ستكون
جاهزه عند موعد استلام اوكرانيا لهذا
النوع من المقاتلات مؤكدا سعيا بلاده
للحصول على مقاتله بريطانيه فرنسيه
الاولويه الاولى بالتاكيد للمقاتله
الامريكيه اف 16 لكنها ليست الوحيده التي
نريد الحصول عليها في المرتبه الثانيه
طائره السويديه
ثم المقاتله البريطانيه تايفون تليها
مقاتله الرافال الفرنسيه لكن اوكرانيا تضع
طائره اف 16 اولويه قصوى الان نحن نجهز
مدارج الطائرات وبحلول الوقت الذي ستحصل
فيه اوكرانيا على اف سته عشر ستكون
مدارجنا جاهزه لا ستقبالها
عوده مره اخرى للعبيد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجي فيما يتعلق بتزويد اوكرانيا
بطائرات اف 16 ما الذي قد تحدثه هذه
الطائرات من تغيير على الارض وكم تحتاج
اوكرانيا من الوقت لاستيعاب هذه الطائرات
وانزلها الى الخدمه
ازدهار هذه الطائرات مهمه للمنظومه
والقتال الهجومي هي تؤمن السيطره الجويه
وفي نفس الوقت تؤمن التغطيه الجويه للهجوم
المفترض والذي في حاله التعثر اليوم ولكن
دائما هذه المنظومه منظومه الطائرات هي
منظومه معقده بحد ذاتها نتحدث عن المدارس
نتحدث عن الرادارات نتحدث عن التصليح تعهد
نتحدث عن الذخيره
الطيار تدريب الطيار وبالتالي القتال من
ضمن مجموعه معينه مع باقي الاسلحه حتى
الان هناك ثمانيه طيارين يتكلمون
الانجليزيه حسب المعلومات ذهبوا للتدرب
ولكن هناك ايضا 20 من يتدربون او يتعلمون
اللغه الانجليزيه وهذا امر يتطلب وقت فاذا
نحن امام مرحله فعلا جديده ولكن هي عامل
حاسم ولكن حاليا ليس هناك من تاثير على
ارض المعركه وقد تدخل في المعركه كما يقال
بمارس القادم 2024 شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي